you're ever announcing something and you  need everyone in your company to like do  something that no one else wants to do  one of the biggest mistakes you can make  is get on a zoom call and say guys shame  on you you haven't filled it out let's  do better the real way to do it sake you  guys are so amazing like 90 of you guys  already filled it out if you haven't  done it please go ahead and get it done  by the end of the day because you're the  stragglers and you know who you are so  go get that done the difference is  people want to be a part of the majority  and when you say no one else has done it  then identify like okay i'm safe i'm  part of the majority and i'm doing the  right thing what you want to do is make  them feel like the minority and you make  the minority what you don't want them to  do and by aligning themselves that way  you can get more people to do what you  want them to do